let's get right to stephen a smith who's
on the phone and steven thank you for
taking the time to come on i know you
just got off the air and you're
hopping right on with me and i greatly
appreciate it
no problem buddy how are you how's
everything going it's good i'm shaking
off the rust
you know it's been a year since i sat in
the chair so i have to get used to
things not blow through breaks and the
like but you know what we're so far so
good
they haven't fired me yet there's no
rush you can handle it
they haven't fired me yet so it's good
steven i've known you for years you can
handle it
we've been friends for 20 years so uh
and that's a long time in this business
stephen what is happening in seattle
what is going on um listen russell
wilson's tired of getting beat up
gotta get hit too much and you know
according to
the reports he met with them before
games uh this season
and he was similarly dismissed when he
made suggestions
on what it would take to improve the
team and to prevent him from stop
getting beat up and hit too much and
they ignored them and he stormed out of
the room and you know one of the things
that i repeatedly state
on on many occasions is this this is
america
and the reason why i say that is because
people want to act
every everybody it doesn't work that way
that's just fool's gold the reality of
the situation is that
people who are special and make
significant contributions
hold more value than those who don't and
you could summarily dismiss some rookie
or some marginal player
or somebody that's a bench warmer or
somebody that doesn't produce for you
exponentially
but when you have a superstar like a
russell wilson
who's never had a losing season in his
nine years as a starting quarterback in
seattle seahawks
who went to back-to-back super bowls
who's won a super bowl championship
was carried the franchise on his
shoulders you know pretty much for the
last five or six
years it's one thing for you to go in a
different direction in terms of not
you know really absorbing his suggestion
it's another thing entirely to make him
feel
like he's being dismissed and you're
devaluing his
input when you do something like that
and then you ask those great players
to go out there and be great it's
significantly tougher
because they've got appeal from some
place different
to be inspired enough to perform
to the degree that they're accustomed to
because now the saddle
with you know salty feelings
about playing for you because they're
not just producing for themselves
they're producing for you making you
feel
like you're right and you're bigger than
what you are when they know in their
hearts
you don't deserve that that's a
difficult situation
and you've got too many organizations
not just in the world of sports
but beyond that want to treat folks
who are stars like they're just marginal
contributors
and that will always come back to haunt
you so read me the tea leaves stephen a
smith what happens how does this end up
what do you think is going to be the end
result
i think that pete carroll is smart
enough
not to trade in all world play
i think the only way russell wilson ends
up being gone
is if he demands a trade and he makes it
incredibly ugly
leaving them no choice but to move in a
different direction
i don't see him being that kind of guy i
think he's the kind of guy
that is class personified and he's very
very big
on not really you know doing something
like that
that's how i view him but i just don't
know how it's going to end up right now
so how do you spin that around then for
desean watson and the situation with the
texans with what he's trying to do
because he's a class act he's a good kid
and he's just trying to get to a place
where he wants to play but
have you ever seen anything so strange
as what's going on right now in houston
in any way i gotta tell you what
resonates with me in houston is that
somebody did something to deshaun watson
um less than a year ago
he signs what is it a four-year
extension
160 million over 100 million guaranteed
and then all of a sudden he's like get
me the hell up out of here
someone did something to him that's not
about football
because the reality is that when he got
that contract
they had lost in an afc divisional
playoff game
to the kansas city chiefs where
they had either 17 or 24 point lead
and kansas city proceeded to score 41
straight points
and the dude was still happy to be there
happy to stop his contract tearful
that the organization trusted him so
much
and grateful to them and then in this
shorter period of time
he's completely done with them somebody
did something to that man i'm convinced
that they lied to him
they did something because there's no
way on earth that you switch
from feeling that way in one season
knowing that parody exists in the nfl
knowing that you can go
from a has been or no good team to a
conference championship game in one year
there is no way on earth that he's
taking this position
unless something on a very personal
level
happened with him and a hierarchy within
that organization
where he said let me get the hell out of
here i do not appreciate
how they're treating me and i'm not
standing for it it's the only thing that
makes
the only thing that makes sense i think
is what you were saying so stephen a are
you saying that
you believe that he's played his last
snap for the texans
i can't say that because he's not the
only one with his rights he can refuse
to plan
out the season and if he does something
like that any serious enough
susie he'll be gone but the houston
texans
are adamant that they're not moving him
so much so that they're not even
returning phone calls
from people who call to inquire and to
make offers
they're steadfast in their position he's
not going any damn place they're not
letting him go
so to me desean watson if he's going to
be
gone it's because he's so serious that
he has
convinced them that he is willing to sit
out the entire season
in order in order to get the hell up out
of there that's the only way
if he's willing to do that they'd be
absolute fools to hold on to him because
why would you want a quarterback
who's hell bent on moving on that makes
no sense it's kind of productive
and regardless of their stupidity
because clearly they did something
stupid to alienate such a superstar
talent like him
it's hard to believe that they would be
stupid enough that he's willing to sit
out the season
and they still help hold on to him but
you just never know with some of these
guys
you know they have the mindset
organizations that is
that you know what you're not going
anywhere now somebody's going to have to
tell me
even though it's a different situation
because jj watt was there for years
deshawn watson you're hell bent on
telling him he's not going any damn play
but when it comes to jj watt because he
walks into the office
and asked you to let him out of his
contract you say okay
we appreciate you as a service no
problem this makes sense
yeah this makes it the strangest and
most expensive game of chicken
i can ever remember that's right right
that's right and i
i don't know what to make of it again
because i don't cover the houston texas
but i do find that to be a tad bit odd
that you are so
if i mean just letting go of jj y with
no problem
but desean watson wants out can you say
the hell with what your feelings are we
we we're keeping you
against your will i find that to be a
bit interested
somebody's going to send brian gumbel in
there because this is a real sports
story it's very very strange
right he's the best am i right
he's the best stephen a smith here on
the rich eisen show susie schuster in
for rich who do you think wins the nfc
east this fall
nfc i would say to you to dallas cowboys
because i think that prescott will come
back
i think he'll be healthy um they'll have
to franchise tag him and then they gotta
touch a lot of reaching agreement
um they're not that stupid to lose them
and put their you know their season in
the hands of andy dalton i think they'll
do something
uh we'll see what happens but i think
it's by default the eagle situation
obviously is what it is having to rely
on jaylen hurts not a
trader carson uh you've got that
situation going on and then
also you got to take a look at uh the
washington redskins their quarterback
situation
there's nothing plus we don't know
what's going to happen with that so you
got to look at that
and then um you know hey the new york
giants
sacramento we hope he's going to be
healthy daniel jones still a question
mark huge question mark when it comes to
him
uh so but but i do like what joe judge
is doing in every game
every single week you see the new york
giants getting better and that tells me
something about this young coach i think
he's got a lot of promise
i'm very fond of the job that he has
done good lord we love your
cowboys videos by the way rich and i
cannot watch enough of your cowboys
videos they are our favorite thing
we have a minute to go with steven a
smith sorry sorry tj but they are
so funny alex cowboy fans deserve to be
trolls
those are the greatest we have one
minute left to go with you what's your
what's your thought now on lebron i mean
i was talking earlier about nothing
worse than being with
lebron when he's in a bad mood and it
feels a little bit like it felt two
years ago but
where do you see the lakers ending up
this year
i think that the lake is going to end up
in the playoffs and i think that they're
going to end up going home early because
anthony davis is not 100 and i think
even when he comes back
i still don't believe he's going to be
100
so because of that i think they're more
of what you saw last night against utah
come playoff time
then they are what they were what they
would be with a healthy
anthony davis which is at the very least
western conference champion
i don't see this working out for them
this season i think that ultimately he's
not going to be 100
and i don't think there's any way in
hell they could be to the brooklyn nets
without a healthy anthony davis and
based off of what i saw last night i
sincerely doubt they'll be able to beat
a utah jazz team either real quick who
plays steven a smith
in the live-action movie stevenet
he's back who plays oh oh i don't know
i don't know i mean a name like jamie
foxx does come to mind
because because he imitates him with his
cleveland a smith act
which is hilarious um but but i would
say a jamie foxx
because he can imitate me i'm fond of
the michael b jordans and others of the
world but i would say jimmy fallon
who isn't are you kidding who is it who
isn't a fan
i'm a fan of course i'm a 48 year old
woman of course i'm a fan
uh stephen i thank you you came off
three hours of tv and you still came on
the show with me i do appreciate it my
pal
and i appreciate you coming through no
problem my pleasure take it easy we'll
talk soon
stephen a smith here on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that
watch more right here